everybody was gonna come on bastards
I told make it clap they don't believe
me guys we are super excited DJ and
producer Fred Falke here today very
exciting and we right before we went
live we actually passed I was like are
you a big game or a nice Lake yes which
means he's a big gamer so let's right
say hello to brother Todd Gabe how's it
going Meister 42 shady what's up so and
we've also got row e over here I don't
want to neglect row e our own music man
over here and we're gonna see how really
really how much really really knows
about music today all right so really
love Mario Kart and Fred actually helped
me out I couldn't get this thing to work
and he was like dude just press this
button and do this what you want to use
this all right all right go for you want
to drive you want to draw you're the
guest you're the special guys so ro he
hit the a button hey boom ro e you're
down there I'm up there okay Fred's on
the upper upper left and row e so you
you drive like this alright you're like
this is the easiest game on the planet
now rowing here's what you need to know
steer cut to 20 minutes of instructions
you know I like this too is gonna be
your gasps Thank You Z and then and then
this is kind of like sliding around
corners and I think yeah breaks down
yeah and then one is while using your
items so do you have a are you a big
market you're big Mario Kart guy yeah
huge here tell me yeah all right so you
this is your normal you know what you
can actually help me cuz I don't know
about the wheels and stuff only first
choose the character and then all right
everyone first occurs and then we can
change the vehicles and the tires and
dark recon shady it's row e it's like
Joey with an R
it's like Joey with an R Fred's EP alpha
is out now and is a new a new album is
coming out in the summer well it depends
on the next year under which games are
gonna come out
which games take is attend exact the
family gaming the longer the delay wait
exactly what game are you playing now
what gave me a to know hello five and
over oh my god
Oh how's Metal Gear I haven't played it
it's insane and you're a Metal Gear fan
right so it's like getting all the
flashbacks by a nice crazy it's too
addictive oh man I can't I cannot wait
to hear all about it
I haven't even played it but I hear it's
it's like supposed to be it's the last
one it's the last one in the series yeah
whoo they're ending big it's it's
massive like all right so you know what
we we play this with a lot of gas and I
always just say go just keep hitting the
button right through this but what is
actually your strategy here well depends
how you drive like yeah if you like just
to try fast on the line you don't slide
on the corner then you know you don't
you're not gonna take how did you even
get this how do I see that a plus oh I'm
learning oh yeah I've probably played
this game 20,000 times that I've never
seen this screen this is awesome
ro you are in so much trouble it's gonna
be a me ooh you know what I do like the
pink Cadillac because its style as well
as speed you know it's not it's
important to look good out there you
know it's important to look good pilots
cheap exactly hello creeper one two
three three five waited way too lockdown
that handle hello you are yes
hello everyone bath all right Beth gets
to say hi on camera go on lean in Beth
15 minutes get off and O'Malley is
freaking out over here because you do
the networking I'm clearly hole I'm
holding the game up already trying to
pick my yeah just take my time we only
have a special guest here take your time
all right no teams let's do it let's do
it rock three races right oh yeah let's
do it
all right now where are we going right
now I don't worry about this guy he's
gonna be the last no matter what Cup
that you like okay pick the Fred my box
very column the Mount Wario Luke is he
just going down the slope yeah
no like running around I like that
there's no [ __ ] in other words just
get into it I love it I love it
hello hello from Spain says German Sun
is so new I don't have to say that
what's up what's up cream shooter game
Rick so what are some of the influences
that you're looking at in terms of
listening to while you're doing your new
album so many I mean I've been using a
lot 40 sobbin like in 80 stuff oh sweet
oh my god I love it
we love that IDs I was I'm a child Lee
Haiti so I feel like that's a yes I'm
back to all the stuff I was listening on
tapes and stuff that's awesome you went
to an archeological dig yeah it was cool
I go back to the classics for sure
they're classics for a reason
um is it hard for you to do you ever
feel like when you when you are being
like influenced when you're listening to
stuff is it hard to not oh nice I just
now is that wait who's Rowi
a Roiz Donkey Kong I have some sort of
tortoiseshell scenario I have oh there's
a thing that makes me go faster songs do
you forget - a moment of song where it's
just kind of not coming together because
it was something I loved about for
instance when we make videos some of it
kind of feels like a puzzle yeah and you
don't really the problem is you don't
really know what the pieces are exactly
or where are they fits or what pieces
you're missing even I feel you here I
mean for me I always think about like
the Rubik's Cube kind of stuff cuz yeah
yeah some songs you get them instantly
right from the start to the finish it's
like in a blink it's done and it's a cut
they come fully yeah yeah some others
it's like the Rubik's Cube Amin's okay
one face is complete it's good yeah how
do I get bits and everything else is can
yeah he can
the thing is gonna take some time that
can be day we
and and how is it especially having a
deadline like is it a situation like
with alpha and doing your the EP is
there a song that you're the most
product is you it took the hardest work
to do not really there were all very
different approach it's kind of all and
just children like how do you pick your
favorite child exactly and uh but it's
more like the deadline stuff I like
because I think you need to add a point
especially when you work on your own in
the studio you need to know there is a
limit otherwise I can be there forever
and tweak that change that word or
change that note absolutely there's
always more you can yeah exactly this
reason it's like always
I play a lot of video games and stuff
like that and when you when you read
interviews about many people have done
like just classic games they're never
completely satisfied on their you know
they're right yeah if we had more time
maybe we how did this these days you
know the game is great as it is right I
know it's still amazing and coming from
the outside it's an it's an amazing
achievement but then I guess from the
inside it's much different are you evil
on that note are you able to ensure your
music are you just you just hear like ah
no no when it's released yeah I don't
listen for a while I can really you know
yeah I've been listening to that sure
after this then I don't know I lose the
perspective and your friend dawn yeah
forth I'm not bad I'm not used to
mushroom I don't know how to use the
directional pad you'll do seven
he carries a mushroom over there you say
over the finish I said press one for
your way about done an event and I
stopped with two no no no you're gonna
think you guys are afraid like what
could be if you would let me know
hello you used a Twitter now hello flame
B black smokers has drift see I believe
that oh you did that's not the mushroom
now the mushrooms this the mushroom
nobody told me that well now you know
dear now you know right now
all right okay thanks race thank you
Wiener pigs right yeah hey you started
as a bass player
yes ooh I like it I like it the best
instrument yeah what it is right yeah
it's kind of I'd love it it's like I'm a
DJ I make great electronic music there's
no base in any yeah everybody's waiting
for the bass to drive but there's no
driver there's no job and how did that I
mean and being the rhythm is so
important so I mean it's that kind of
how you got into yeah absolutely like I
wasn't basically on I started to hang
around with DJs
right and they were using all these
disco based samples to produce house
trucks yeah
and I mean the bass lines were really
cool you know yeah acting like no no the
brother Johnson zlj whatever yeah and
well Fred can you play the bass light on
that oh sure oh that's cool and then
after I was like maybe I should I should
do my own stuff who are some of your
favorite bass players oh oh this is
where ro he's gonna get me also plays
little bass okay little bit like
different like very different stuff like
I listen to so many different jars
that's good
man I was but I said Lewis Johnson like
was a great great great bass player he's
the one who plays on spoiler
oh wow there we go no we're talking I
don't know I
I need something off to write up Chili
Peppers when I was peeling oh yeah
please amazing right in these stages
like no sold the squeeze is such a one
of my favorite write other songs because
it is just basically bass it's you know
it's basically just bass and singing I
mean it's it's unbelievable I mean the
whole melody is carried within that
within that instrument which is
fantastic
talking about 87 I think one of your
first samples are not mistaken was crush
on you by the Jets right yeah oh my god
that is such a classic isn't amazing
much to cover the artwork and
on the on the EPA the air cuts they have
you can date at other time it's over
time how do you how do you decide
speaking of artwork how do you how do
you decide an artwork for albums and and
how does that yes that's that's such a
not complicated but like there is no
rules really like depending on who
you're working with and for example on
the under on the EP a-- we've been
working with Matt Maitland okay and he's
amazing and he's a fan of my music so
basically when I reached out to him they
responded immediately very positively
yeah and and he's awesome I mean the
first I send in the music and again when
you mentioned earlier you know like you
compare the tracks to your kids which
one you prefer
yeah well it wasn't beat to say I said
my music - Matt and I didn't know and
it's like sending your kids to school
why is he gonna comment with vision is
gonna have do we have a shared vision
yeah oh man we had Oh first the first
ruff is sending we're already amazing
was like wow that's the cover so no it's
just a wrap
oh yeah Felicia it takes to be first ah
that's alright you got to play dirty if
you want to be first so when you do like
something with like I heard that the
Jamiroquai thing you did was awesome I'm
huge fan of that guy does that are they
seeking you out for a remix or how often
are you like hey I think we could do
something really cool - yeah alright so
it's always a an incoming it comes it
comes you over there they come to me and
say I would like you to do rings and I
always do remix because I love the track
or because I'm a fan of the artist yeah
Johnny require huge
I mean that guy's unbelievable the first
time I saw a live in achieving friend
serenity we're promoting the first
island ah huh and so they played his
show gotcha who send the blue shell god
yeah I just you know just you said press
the UP button
you said press several times it says you
got to keep doing it the golden mushroom
lets you shoot as many times as you want
it's going good it's gold brother so
afraid that ah no the rules
you're terrified this game never been
less true I'm not sure there's been a
more false statement spoken on this
couch if you have a Rik d5 guys damn son
looks like oh my god well look at this
now we swing over to YouTube mmm I love
it
and there got some problems today you
know you were still we're still being
still broadcasting on YouTube that's why
we do both baby we don't vote which one
Oh winner picks oh let's do something
from the leaf Cup let's see some elite
you know leaf Cup I'm picking next guys
uh how do we like sherbert land this
will be fun I want from the desert to
the ice yes the ice have you guys seen
the revenant yet you see the red now oh
man talk about ice that movie is amazing
very brutal very brutal but get here
it's rough
yeah very brittle but good it's like you
know you hear about these stories about
them just in the wilderness shooting and
it's like zero degree yeah like I mean
it just sounds like the crazy arduous
shoot
it's insane have you know have you ever
done a music video or anything yeah
we've done a couple for two first
singles in alpha and so and so how does
that go I mean because you want to talk
about artwork on the album this is now
we're talking about a much more serious
oh yeah thing and so how does that work
how do you find a director today they
must bring you a vision yeah exactly you
know they come up to us with their own
vision on the track and we will look at
it and you know we pick up the one that
we
think much ah exactly what we were
thinking about
and so do you go for kind of a music
video vision that relates to how you
think about the song or do you look for
something to contrast that with like oh
like in this like this is why I wrote
this song or yeah in between like even
let's say that if the director has an
idea that's contrasting my vision but in
a very uh I don't know like creative way
and like whoa that's an expected good
yeah yeah I go for that that's awesome
and because I mean you can never really
find someone who's gonna have to send me
and why would you anyway right that's
true yeah thing you know you want to
work is that this director because you
believe in is you know taste and or you
like oh yeah before whatever so you
trust him somehow and what what is kind
of your taste with music videos what do
you like to look for I know you've like
worked with justice and these guys a lot
of guys who have great news videos great
oh man justice unbelievable yeah some
sort of a bomb guys never take this yeah
you need to keep that for the finish
line
yeah carry it over the finish line
that's the toughest box you need to get
once you've done the free laps this is
the advice I'd been looking just ask you
know we're not leaving you astray oh hey
ho hey now a video why I mean duh plenty
like I remember like the Serie of video
from Daft Punk when they did the
discovery album it amazed me because
there was this connection between all
the the singles that eventually lead to
the big animation yeah that was kind of
Wow I think picture was oh my god I know
yeah gondry stuff
yeah half was just unbelievable
was a conan and a gondry video he was he
was in denial twist I think a Gondry
came on our show actually it was cool
his son who's backstage had like he was
like cooler than anyone the kid was like
maybe eight had like a mohawk it was not
a skateboard as I go this kid is so cool
way cooler than I will ever be he's
already eight he's just a mean he's only
eight oh no don't do that what happened
I'm doing nothing I've got time I move
that blue shell I've got time yes
oh really damn it ooh and I am doing
tired of all this or the blue shell
always comes five seconds to the finish
line okay oh okay I'm tense you guys is
horrible from 12 to 7 they can't see you
when you stand up they can't see you
Gillis I look ridiculous the worst I
miss or not winter ice or in-between a
weenie
all right let's do know you should we up
the cc's to 150 make a little bit faster
hey let's talk about it come on I hate
myself
all right here we go oh yeah what now
what do you think about that actually
people in the shadow bring I think what
what about video game music what do you
wonder do you even because video game
music is an interesting cat because hey
hey hey it's it's got its got inspire
you right it's got a kind of effect you
get yeah but then also it can't be
annoying because it's always playing
it's kind of you know so I mean if it's
good you don't notice it I mean he's
just part of the game as much as the
graphics or the storyline right if it's
annoying I just bring the game back to
gamestop
as music ever killed the game for you if
you've been like I can't I have place on
you yeah I mean the game was bad I was
too young to notice that the music was
pretty horrible it was pit fighter on Oh
although I will say some kind of fun
crunchy crunchy
currency instruments like back in like
the 8-bit 16 days that stuff is pretty
fun and you want to go 80s I mean that's
that's very 80s oh it is video game
music is it's crazy do you think video
game music is influenced to you somehow
maybe in your FTP yes it's I think I've
listened to so much music through to
video game mom I cannot be somewhere
there so and it's weird like you know
you think like did I did it did it
everybody know it's like there you go
that's right you know everyone knows
like the hook is amazing oh my god it's
so it's like yeah it's like conic it's
very weird alright here we go let's go
150 here we go all right you know row
you choose where do you know where do
you want to play let the newbie pick one
remix wario stadium needs a funky slappy
bassline Mario Kart remixes that's
awesome that is like a child
rainbows huh get a plate yes exactly
geez land oh my god take your time dude
sound like people are watching please
she's lame Jesus thank you thank you
Jesus dude there you've got a chance I
know because I didn't get that one so I
don't love it I love it guys okay
alright you want to point people to
youtube who they're asking in the thing
since it's since we're still streaming
on YouTube
it's tweeting good whew the chain shops
I love those I need one of those for my
yard keep the kids off the lawn I'll
keep the kids off the lawn the old Chain
Chomp
man oh I didn't know I was choosing this
weird little thing okay I never play
that race is there a point where when
you're working on something and you're
you're you know in your time off you're
listening to other music that maybe can
inspire you is there a point where you
go
this is inspiring me versus like now I'm
just trying to rip this off find
creative line where is that yeah you
have to man is that totally okay yeah I
mean it's very hard because I mean
obviously when you listen to stuffing
it's there as I said yeah when we
mentioned the video game music and then
it was coming back at a point so unless
you really rip it off like on purpose
oh it's okay yeah whatever because I've
heard people who were like oh I was just
I was just trying to do like a rolling
stone as I was ripping off Nick jet like
whatever and you're like great it's a
great song that's totally fine I think I
think you know and plus ever you draw
that inspiration from yeah you're
comfortable with it yeah and those guys
also too you know there's shades of what
those guys listen to you oh for sure and
that goes I think for any artistic
endeavor you talk about writing you're
talking about comedy you're talking
about I mean you could see you know
Conan is such a big fan of you know Mel
Brooks and these guys call right you can
see and eat Johnny Carson I mean you can
see the influence there too and that's
kind of fun to pick that stuff apart to
Riley oh my god video games like I mean
Mario Kart doesn't quite you know and
you know dozens of other developers to
do the phone cop race not the Formula
One oh yeah for sure
some of them are actually very good
absolutely and it that that's always the
most exciting thing to me especially
music cuz I I mean I love you know I
always have music playing and Spotify
was gigantic if anything me like in the
studio I have okay I always have like a
movie plane oh really yeah I normally I
turn the song off or I think the volume
very low but I love to have a movie oh
that's cool I love it now what do you
now what does it what does a movie
determent like if you're working on
something heavy it is it
or the movies kind of just rainin I just
put a movie that I not necessarily
connected to what I'm doing at the
moment
yeah he's just I don't know I just like
movies yeah that's awesome would what
are some of the ones that you that for
the album you're working on now what is
something that acquaintances video like
what was the last movie that was playing
in the studio the last one is a movie
called less than zero
Oh less than zero yeah it's a kind of
80s movie yeah oh no Donna knew who
directed it just like it's the story of
just kids in LA in the 80s music moving
was the music oh my god I think I just
figured out the sliding thing
well I'm 22 I'm getting worse
oh we're back at twitch dad - hello
again twitch although hello still
YouTube YouTube you were there the whole
time you know you didn't abandon us
YouTube um that's really cool I love the
idea of taking inspiration from other
other are you into like art at all in
terms of like paint or sculpt already
that's my only I love movie posters oh
wow okay oh that's an art all in itself
yeah it is that's an easy do you have
any like originals any oh yes oh wow
what's the crown jewel of your
collection yeah actually it's a Japanese
movie poster from Raiders of the Lost
Ark Wow the artwork is quite unusual
like well Japanese artwork on the
posters is always taking a different
approach sure to whether it is American
or European but on this one the
interesting thing is like instead of
putting Harrison Ford as the main stuff
on the poster its Spielberg Lucas it's
like behind the scene picture of like
both directions awesome and then you are
like this kind of small inserts of
Harrison Ford in the movie stuff it's
really cool and I actually I brought I
brought the poster for framing the other
day and I was watching it and I never
noticed that but like at the bottom you
see the dunes and the Sun you know we're
in the movie
yes yes yes and I never noticed but the
one on the poster is actually a model
and that they were using as a you know
pre prod stuff there is a there is a
picture on consider the Internet of
first Gilbert watching how we will look
and that that comes from its pictures
like zooming on them
you can notice the moving I gotta do
everything different over there done
that's awesome I will say like I do love
you know one of my favorite things is
there's this great YouTube series called
every frame of painting which is it's
kind of like this guy who just loves
movies he'll dissect little things about
movies and one of the episodes is on
translation and and he's talking about
Japanese translation you know or how
movies are seen all over the world and
how how different it is and their uses
as an example there is a gangster scene
okay so these guys are gonna go these
guys are gonna go beat up whatever like
I already go beat up these other guys
and English is just like alright let's
go get them and in the literal Japanese
translation is let us go show these men
are influenced and it's so interesting
because they're it's just so different
but I mean it's kind of the same idea
but it's so so much more subtle and
beautiful in that way and what's more
creepy by the way very well a lot you
know but I just love that and and it's
interesting too because you know music
is the ultimate language I mean I think
a lot of kpop lately which is a little
bit of a guilty pleasure for sure but no
guilt but you know but I have no idea
what they're talking about
yeah I knew I was in a safe space thank
you
you know but it is it's I can I still
enjoy it as much as any song in English
which is like fantastic when I grew up I
was listening to English songs I could
in this alright really what are we
playing oh uh I guess we'll go dragon
drift trip way yeah hmm this is the one
I don't know that I'm reading this is
the one I don't know I played this level
prepare yourself he's your sing
oh I'm purpley
prepared said the guy who just came in
and would have been 12th of that for the
last-minute bullet you can you can also
hold the controller opposite all right
with my feet with Mario Cart foot pedals
in here that would actually be kind of
fun I gotta say like just like that's
crazy I want to learn how to fly a plane
this year because I'm insane and the big
thing about planes I'm realizing is
there's pedals that you have to feel
yeah oh my god I had no idea it's
terrible I shouldn't I can barely drive
a car I don't know why watching yourself
learn some organ first maybe a harp you
know exactly those I remember like it's
just a couple years ago eyes similar
ways the harp looks like the easiest
instrument and then it's like well it's
got like 16 petals that you never see
and it's just like oh of course it's not
just it's like one of the most
complicated instruments out there people
keep bumping me and I don't appreciate
this it's not bumper cars um what kind
of what are you do you have you must
have certain keyboards and pieces of
coming you that you're just in love with
in the studio yeah what was what's the
most recent addition to your to the
studio that you're excited about the
most recent is like it's not technically
a keyboard but is electronic drum sets
oh nice one day we're using the eighties
actually oh no Simmons yeah and uh I
found out that they were using that on
the we all the world Wow yeah one that
sound that's awesome how do I get it
eBay eBay oh my god best worst thing to
ever be based transform the universe
because of that stuff yeah yeah and eggs
like reinvented hoarding isn't that is
awesome do you are you not superstitious
at all in terms of the instruments you
use like like your hat you're creatively
blocked to be like I'm gonna go to the
you know where the role in whatever you
no not really like I have some pieces
that I love yeah but I tend to really
renew like my studio set up Constantine
oh really
well that's kind of cool yeah cuz you
having tinker yeah you got it a
cryptogram yeah because the thing is
like I think comfort zone can be very
dangerous sorry I keep you're sitting in
your studio is your favorite piece of
gear that you know you're gonna get good
sound of a Dada yeah you become somehow
non-creative at four okay you know too
much you know thinking oh I have this
thing to back me out like this sins is
gonna worry about yeah do you have I
mean do you have any kind of tricks if
you have writer's block or something
like that - kind of yeah and read and
figure out yourself I I just exactly
this is your trick comes on Monday melee
every single time yeah I will say there
is a certain there is a certain kind of
Zen Zen quality to playing video games
that does I feel like Hailey's you know
especially like when I'm having trouble
like writing jokes or whatever it is
like let's just take our mind off it you
know and then all of a sudden your
subconscious is working the whole time
and this I'm playing Call of Duty online
and someone just keep like beating me up
no you go back to the studio and destroy
your new you're on terms it holstered
you on eBay are you are you are you able
to move old equipment out as much as you
bring in new things like can you say
goodbye or do you hoard like because one
day I might need to go back to that
keyboard or that piece of equipment or
are you like I think I've done all I can
do here and I'm you set it free at the
end of every album you throw some
massive box with the FedEx tags on it
yeah I'm like I look at the box it's not
robbed completely eye-opening
and then the Finnish guy ring the bell
you sell everything just FedEx package
yeah right exactly that would be by the
way a horrible job for a hoarder being
like you know delivery here all right
bro here we go last last one of the
again oh yeah I like judo my go elect
her down my neck for them cuz of all the
pretty lights oh it's so pretty it's so
pretty
are you in the club yeah you're the
[Laughter]
exactly Jemez savvy 201 what's up how's
it going
you lucky bastard sister Jude that's
right if you're just joining us from the
front fog today DJ and producer you can
get its IEP alpha it's out now a new
album coming next year I know I do you
have a title for the new album
no perfect how about ro e sucks at Mario
Kart as a good row is awesome at
beatboxing no no and then just 45
minutes of me going yes you can't lie as
an album title row e please this is
actually a very pretty level oh he says
I have a plant I have some sort of a
planter compliant oh my god I got
fireballs Oh God to find a restroom what
you see it's like we're in the Venetian
there's like how do we get out of here
it's 4:30 in the morning worse the 4:30
in the afternoon it looks like they're
all drinking martinis
that's that 4:30 in the morning martini
that really does yeah they'll say that
so I went to the yeah over the weekend I
went to my friend works for Disney so I
went to the Zootopia wrap party which is
super fun
it was a good time and they made
everybody dress up in suits which is
kind of interesting because you know in
our rap we don't have a wrap party but
our Christmas parties you know people
kind of dress up nice but people kind of
get sloppy I think it really kept
everyone on their best behavior because
you kind of looked you know you don't
want to throw up on your suit maybe just
for that exact that oh that's the only
reason but yeah it was really funny I
was talking to one of the the music guys
there and he also worked on frozen yeah
and it was just I was like how many
times have you heard let it go and he's
like dude I can't let it go he's like
hundreds of thousands and it's funny
because just like any parent oh yeah by
the way yeah I know the but yeah you
know those I will say that the it's
always funny when you when you see a
movie and the song is like a breakout
song always feels a little weird to me
because it's a you know it's like part
of the story that they're telling you
know it's like going to the jungle did
it do now I'm gonna listen to that my
car like what that's very weird
I've never really been a show tunes guy
but yeah I don't know you do you like
show tunes or no yeah I have to say
because it is kind of a thing like I
don't know they I've got the golden mosh
yeah I'm good again I say can keep
pressing in yes to never the whole thing
okay no it's gone thank you for once was
that so hard guys I don't know tell me
I'm in 12 I'm in nine it seems hard it
seems hard oh my god done this is awful
I'm sorry you guys are gotta wait for me
I got I'm still fighting my way to the
bathroom huh I was cut cut - oh my god
this is horrific
jossey-bass show tunes is a word brandon
damn son what kind of base you got I
have I have a Fender Jaguar yeah that's
a newer one yeah I have a shoe
I have a oh you were with me when I
bought it I have an Epiphone Les Paul
five-string that we that's right that's
right
Sam Sam s on 48th Street for 200 bucks
it's the best heaviest like most
wonderful giant mellow cheap crappy but
awesome bass no it's a lot of adjectives
I it's I it's always there and it's
always great do you want to play a game
where we all chase each other let's do
it
he's down Fred's down you just put the
controller down it's a very it's a VR
game is the older than me it's a PR game
all right hold on one second I will take
from the Internet's suggestions of games
for a six-year-old if people know like
any games for kids and I'm down for
suggestions dude this game we're about
to play it's a great kid would introduce
my kids to gay man but like without all
the murder
sure sure his dad doesn't like why did
you watch me play the the Star Wars
Battlefront and then when my son was
like daddy kill him I was like try to
slapping these guys harder than a
vintage P base we are getting history
right it's killing us are we gonna play
like you killed Mario chase no chase
alright do you want to be the chaser or
do you want to be the chasey you want
should we chase you yeah you want to
chase us well chase it'll be a very
short day this you take this alright bro
a minecraft splatoon minecraft thank you
Pokemon there's a platoon splatoon Oh
based on the movie it's dark but all
your kids will appreciate it okay
exactly these are all these are all
goodness suggestions thank you I will
forget them all and we're done with this
oh I'm Jordan s I see how this is going
exactly all right and start 80
milliliters so you are going to look at
this yeah and you're gonna run not gonna
lose yeah yeah we can't we can't we
can't look at this yeah
and really we're holding it like this
and we're gonna run with this and then
when we get close we tackle them there's
all the communication triangle seeing
eye contact okay I get exactly all right
let me stare into each other's eyes
eventually kiss eventually we kiss
broadcast so we have basically two
minutes to catch him so I think hit both
the triggers there did these perfect
Jordan s so we just got a catching dude
and it'll it'll say you see hey there
you are right it'll see how far away we
are
[Applause]
Joyce chamber all right all right so I'm
in the upper left row he's in the bottom
right Fred were chasing Fred all right
I'm going up
I think he's so should be easier wait I
see him I see him I hear me now it is
you he said where's yet wait now is he
looking like up top of the thing top
rail oh I see oh I'm going down I'm
going down to cut off you're very close
the opposite way damn it
how's it you double fast he's quick when
he's somewhere huh where is he going
missing he's sneaky he's always been on
metal gear you got it splatoon we got ya
we'll give her another chance we have
Fred no chance here we go I got it yet
so that Solid Snake would be ashamed all
the weight in phantom pain and panic man
you play big boss right yeah it's big
boss venom snake Oh venom snake right
right that's awesome yeah cuz he's the
guy who saw the snake was cloned from
right has that video yeah can you
explain Metal Gear Solid can you explain
the plot
offensively yeah
I don't I don't the I always laugh hey I
know a little bit I think I played the
first one okay so now Oliver Ocelot was
great but in the mind guy you put the
thing yeah so basically takes place in
in in the 80s right so that's the funny
thing about the Syriac phantom phantom
pain is the last middle gear game that
it takes place in the middle of the
serie of game Castello the previous game
which was metal gear 4 on ps3 yeah is
the last one like oh oh yeah timeline I
mean it's kind of messy but it's great
that's on so yeah in the 80s and you are
a big bus yeah after nine years coma
like it takes place after this game
called Peace Walker okay so that's the
that's the it's like a scene in the next
season so yeah and you wake up in this
hospital in Malta I think and all of a
sudden you have to run away because
people are chasing you like here it's
big more it's a little more intense but
it's basically yes it's like that maybe
Kojima played and was like okay this
isn't him I would love it if what about
doing this in a hospital Malto is people
this will be great for see and yeah I'm
just a middle of the game now so I don't
know where this is going oh my god
that's awesome it's really intense now
to hear it's really fun especially for
for for super fans because it kind of
shows you a lot of times how these guys
became how they are options you
mentioned Austin Lutton a game Ocelot is
your Eli right well I've been fighting
in the previous one piece walkers
shortly then if you play the fourth yeah
you know Ocelot is a villain right yes
now he's helping you and you can see yes
and you kind of see how it's kinda cool
basically it's like like they do with
Star Wars like you know if it's at four
or five six and then the next one where
two one two three yes like that
yeah the only thing I've understood that
you said in the last did you see sir
what you see the new Star Wars but not
yet oh man
in a lot you're gonna let us go there
from his grave done it's great yeah I
haven't seen it but I'm a huge stalls oh
yeah go no worries it was really funny
is have you played a great Star Wars
Battlefront at all you play battlefront
no not yet because I'm very I'm focused
on one game when I play I'm like yes yes
so for now it's Metal Gear in Halo 5 and
that's it that's all yeah I mean those
are that's a those are two huge game so
you've got you work cut out for you I uh
there is but I will say it was really
funny uh
and I just noticed this when I started
oh and I just David I just noticed this
when I started playing battlefront but
it's amazing how the sounds are so
here's got the beat up from Bella phone
was amazed because it looks like the
movie come on all the sounds have grew
up on you know yeah absolutely
and like my fighters a kids yeah that
weird like weird skin like the
skittering around just great but yeah
that that game is super fun
I got a play oh man come on I'm Jesus
this mud is the worst ah fast and he's
invincible to starve where is he he's up
best player available no now we're
playing Nintendo land Mario chase that
Nintendo land which is a great super fun
game where did you go
ah Nick Phantom battlefront is a pretty
fun game it's very I mean I will say
it's a little one-dimensional but it is
really really fun especially when you
get to be a like the one of the heroes
like the lightsabers I started it and
then I fell into the trap of the
multiplayer online business so yeah I'm
just your CI did you get it and now I'm
just losing to God ten-year-olds from
the you know I know it is a little
disheartening wait to you you play
online a lot right do you play Halo and
all that stuff multiplayer online yes
hello as these new I mean there's this a
multiplayer game called warzone that's
amazing oh my god
like multiplayer versus I add the same
it's a big mess but it's really really
cool that's awesome
we got the yeah we we got I got you yes
how you jump to catch me you see what I
do I ask you questions go for it and I
go for it I love it all right here you
guys me you guys chased me yeah we want
asking questions now yeah this is my
favorite part cause you can see how
terrible I am yeah watch the blue I was
just like wandering around watch I went
up into like northeast corner these kind
of sneaking thought that was really
brave brave you got see the eye that was
the worst because yeah yeah that you're
so fast at that start insane yeah the
grandpa oh there we go it's recommend to
see the Star Wars movies for five to
eight to six is that very order any
order is the way I'm gonna do with my
son wait what's a machete or Shetty
order is you go for five so you stabbed
sorry by you called the machete you
because you're lopping off you're
cutting it up but you can also have the
option to lop off one completely and
never have to see it okay because it
gives you nothing
and by the way spoiler alert if you
haven't seen Star Wars and if you
haven't seen one through six you have
other problems so it basically goes for
five so we establish the father-son
dynamic and then you go back and do a
flashback to three okay now he it neatly
keeps together the sibling thing oh I've
been code okay but this simply got you
the size on a six they give you at the
end of three so it carries one right
into the other got it and let's face it
one is nothing and yeah one what do we
do oh my god
although they bring him back as some
kind of crazy Sith badass it would be
kind of hilarious um there was some
theory that that Jar Jar is like a UH
the jar Jar has some sort of force
abilities
I know it's a great ability that was the
voice from God that's me ah
who's that just lie down okay
that's bleach oh I can't come on get for
the star oh wait no no it's never gonna
catch me never gonna get it never gonna
get it
hey we're both up here yeah it's cool
here look at the view it's amazing Oh
what he's not coming from the stars boy
hey where are you no no no we're never
gonna catch me yeah just keep talking
about star wars fellas you are you
Knights you oh we should do it I'm doing
Solid Snake crown over here you're just
standing next to her he's not moving
next time he's not moving very sliding
poison oh yeah nice no that's me great
have you moved in the last two minutes
I'm moving everywhere no no he's not
moving oh yeah show yourself strong just
like free blade yeah I forgot there's a
camera me the whole time oh so sneaky so
sneaky
humiliating yeah that's right oh yeah
make sure to check out our show tonight
its mission Conan where we would go to
Qatar
we traveled over to the Middle East to
Air Base and Qatar and with the first
lady Michelle Obama which is fantastic
and that that episode airs today oh look
at this look at a sleeve these moves
look at these moves see you got to know
in the whole of know to follow them
you're not playing you're dancing here
yeah dukedom jutsu man look at you
jukebox
every good now we chase Rowi okay it's
gonna be quite a quite that's right yes
Conan is pro gamer Jesus Tony that's
right that's right
uh what was our have you ever been to
San Diego comic-con no never oh you
gotta go it's crazy it's really crazy a
lot of crazy
yeah our show went last year which was a
blast and I would go again this yeah and
I believe we're going again this year
yeah so we'll do the slides again yeah
it's really really fun are you fan of
comic books and that stuff no reaiiy
mean that no there's so much there I
mean ya know it's all like animation I
mean in France we grew up really on like
Japanese animation
yeah more than pies that I wonder just
because I don't know like some guide
appointment a decision to buy rights of
Japanese whoa that's awesome I really
love have to say like Oh wowie oh yeah
keep riding right oh look at that I
don't realize I have a map and I can see
where you nerds are oh yeah oh that's
the whole thing
we'll see how unfair it is okay I get
you see him he's in red
okay okay okay here we go you're right
behind you here we go oh I like this
little music there was a time when I was
really into acapella music and I was
just like now that pentatonix is ko oh
here we go
yeah okay I'm gonna cut them off the
pass here okay I'm going I'm going green
we do our classic two four five yeah two
four five wait I can't wait to punch you
right in the face on the game of course
oh oh I win the exact wrong way
damn it in the blues only to murder you
so hard punch you so hard you're gonna
crap a fist oh yeah okay Green Zone I'm
in the green I made the dream idols if
I'm in the green I'm literally running
in the green zone
oh he's in the red zone is on the top
the star all right here we go here we go
got him mark dim mark dumb here we go
he's a blue he's in blue blue going up
to the top yeah I'm going on the other
side
oh no it's good he's gone now to blue oh
dude I hate you even more with the
charger voice is that possible
your impersonation is amazing here we go
come on laugh it up ah okay okay I'm so
close one-handed yeah you get him yeah
it's the paid for the most you could
guess those latest fingers look at this
finger it's red from hate just pressing
down as hard as possible well I'll
deposit roie's windpipe yeah my battery
oh yeah I can't wait for a minute long
me just like on roie's ass you wanted to
send me a postcard address it to Rosie's
ass is that right was that I'll watch
your coat
alright this is dick are you all right
over there that's me using the force I'm
just like hmm look at the oh here we go
look at this I'm so close Evan and there
got pretty gnarly
whoo pretty gnarly says to go look
there's a patch of the word there's a
path there is it yeah okay let's do that
again
wait God we need to do another one I
need a we need a rematch me ah all right
yes for your hubris charger again just
for your hubris charger I'm not afraid
let's do this slide level I'm not afraid
bring him on bring it not afraid I love
it Brandon Jeff use a favorite clueless
gamer we've done I don't know the next
one I say the next
I think is gonna be the my favorite one
we do a thing on our shower cone and I
play video games on the air and he cuz
he I want to do something where he was
stupid and I was smart because he's so
much smarter than I am
it sounds like he doesn't anything about
video games just guy went to Harvard but
that you didn't play any Mario didn't
which is hilarious so I could finally
beat him it's something all right here
we go
are we're gonna learn a lesson there's a
pattern there's there was a pad I feel
like it was a figure eight definitely
definitely
oh it's it that was you I think oh I
wish there was it is a little
frustrating if they only run at one
speed it makes me crazy my breath oh I
know and I can assume to be comfortable
in the greens don't don't Oh God don't
let these hands kill again how quickly
we get arrogant so I cut to five minutes
ago on Rainbow Road Mario Kart wait oh I
see him there is various okay blue I go
right exactly
here we go nope nope nope doubled back
did I oh did i I've never seen the
roadie this happy yeah
or this about to be murdered by I know
your office is really I remember like I
know when you're in it we're holding
those mushrooms and you didn't know what
to do oh wait I think he's over is that
him
no that's ma'am hi Susan I know it's you
and right yeah yeah that's me if it's
somebody if it's a handsome mushroom
then it must be me yeah he's on the top
how much time I wait here we go yeah
copied the map I just need
oh no I didn't want to go down the slide
oh okay all I say he's a blue he's in
blue I thought he was in blue how you
doing good this time
I'm running over towards red that's you
close though let's hear hear let's hear
your Chewie I know you can do it we're
getting them all in here get them all in
oh all right things that top do you
there is no right the end what oh man
look at them man the worst ah
I think it's ghost time I think we play
a little ghost
Luigi ghost mansion what I'm gonna
flavor ichigo's man's yeah oh yeah Fred
Fred's down Fred's down row EEZ wind
says buttlicker 14 all right okay so you
got a fan in butt licker perfect classic
classic OE fan they pass there's more
comment axis when I fear close gamers
are you fighting game fan at all or no
you like they'll fighting yeah I used to
honest and I'm completely out now hi
guys I don't know either move its the
moves you have to know all the moves and
stuff I just can't stop it was I there
was this game pull king of fighter and
yes come the first time I saw Street
Fighter though on okay that was like
what's going on here six bottoms yeah
but that was it that was a movie
brothers
that was my yeah it was mind-blowing I
gotta see you like I used to be able to
keep up with all the stuff and then it's
just way too complicated I mean I'm
probably like three generations and that
are you saying I know yeah this is this
is this also has like nineteen Buster's
on it also so and this is like the the
easy version the easy from last time I
played a fighting games against younger
kids I felt like my parents asking me to
you know it's all glammed VHS so yeah
how does this all what do i all right
here we go just pick so point it you
want to point are you can use their you
can use the controller I can point yeah
yeah bro is the Star Wars guy with all
the voices who I haven't played Luigi's
Mansion on GameCube no I have it that's
fine all right do you want to be ghosts
you wanna be goes first okay here we go
here we go all right so row he hears yes
please oh whoops whoops I messed it up
sorry oh wait what happened I just hit a
there we go alright so he Fred's gonna
be the ghost and we are going to be the
ghost hunters
he's also the ghost kind of looks like
an egg with two of yeah it's it's I
don't know what's going twisted it's
weird he's Jen enough from the other day
crazy uh and so when he gets close to
you we're not gonna be able see him it
gets close to you your things that are
vibrate I love it so call it out all
right and now when you can use the the
two button to shine the flashlight on
him and where's the flower one I'm
stupid whatever and then a sidestep sigh
oh my god well you know more than what
this guy's got Leo it's confidence this
guy's the auditor running away I ran
away oh I'm so good at everything I'm
gonna run some more yeah exactly
death gunner three yes we do this every
Monday it's very fun alright so here we
go
[Music]
looking good and you know you do we're
pretty of ghost suit pretty well for act
to say thanks what Stella made yes
custom it's couture ghost what's the
code words if we were vibrating Oklahoma
Oklahoma gorgeous time vibrating works
well Ivan I'm diving I've added damn
mm-hmm it was a resistant six ah I do
like horror games I'm trying to get the
last word game I played that I really
liked I liked until dawn was kind of fun
have you flooded in these games Fred
that are kind of like Ivan
dude you gotta call it out before he
grabs you okay I'll work on that
mmm-hmm I'm vibing vibing ball God he's
in the corner he's in the corner get him
I'm gonna come this way way way do we
get out riding vibing
two for two and thankfully yeah oh he's
in the other what side step look I'll
see you back you see vibing vibing also
your thing runs down after what oh he's
close he's real close
what's that a battery battery I'm dead
the gap he's gonna get me oh he carried
me oh that's harsh
oh you just disappear I got to come back
now here we go
vibing vibes so many vibes so many fun
um I got you I got your back bro I got
vibes okay you know you just keep
yelling out I have vibes it doesn't help
you're constantly vibing our recent us
know when you're not vibing you can't be
you do you were rather worried he's
surviving too much you're the word Hydra
yes you vibe this oh my god Avadh oh god
you're coming back so slow oh there he
is
we're mine I'm reviving you oh sorry
he's back thank you
so many vibes oh my god you got to get
it together you guys want to play that
other game again right chase you yeah
you didn't have your you weren't your
head was in the game I was dead and on
the floor just screaming I'm vibing you
don't even know that means rating that
star chase was yeah ridiculous are you
like you like horror movies first of all
yeah oh man favorites yeah you got any
favorites come to class I mean so
obviously like all day album and stuff
was back 80s I would go bit further for
the 70s worth Dawn of the Dead whoa love
Donna dead Romero's I think the classic
have you seen um one of my favorite ones
that had a very 80s vibe was it follows
did you see that if you haven't you
would absolutely like me because the
thing bact I mean yeah when I was a kid
in France like all the movies good like
a different title oh sure okay
sometimes it was very we had some people
then you know I start to talk about the
movie I'm like never heard of star
fights
oh you mean Star Wars yes yeah it
follows is because it's aesthetically
early 80s like it like the set design
all that stuff and the music is very
very like kun kun it's very like John
Carpenter yeah oh it's so great it's
really really fun
I do love but one thing I really love
about horror movies is the simplicity of
in a horror movie
you know like like here are the rules
you fall asleep this guy with a bunch of
knives on his hands comes to kill you
right Freddy Krueger and and this it
follows is just if you eat this thing it
just follows you in unless you sleep
with someone else then it follows them
okay so that's it and you can't stop it
it's always follow you you just have to
run away you have to go yeah exactly you
got to go rent out a lot for no knows
where you are exactly all right well
let's give it again wait while we change
in this row he wants to be the ghost oh
I'm feeling ghosty yeah you want it you
want to kill you want to kill Rowan I do
I would love I'd love to kill what are
the buttons all you do is you walk
around just look at ya you walk around
you just have to bump into us because
it's too close for them no it's good
it's good okay
holy vertically yeah going back and
forth I'm waving I love it I love it oh
do I have a favorite Star Wars character
who Darth Maul is cool I like Darth
Maul's looks of us
I don't you a favorite Star Wars
character pencil not so yeah exactly
he's the best it's that obvious cuz it's
the best answer is why it's obvious ro e
is it toboggan laugh fuzzball uh yeah I
look hot solos awesome I mean come on
Boba Fett got it yeah that's amazing
what about alders are the bounty hunters
now yeah yeah we're big Luke yeah
cares yeah I know the nothing happens
but I got it all yeah what was the best
oh yeah so he said it follows soundtrack
is so dank I'm gonna say that dank means
good
so dig okay thanks good it was good
those dank memes oh no oh he's close
he's real close take that oh dude Moreno
oh man oh you're so dead
oh this is great oh we got it we got it
oh yeah I got zapped I got them they got
me on the photos can do it oh he's close
to me oh I'm not a batteries team Danny
but now now well who r2d2 or bb-8 well
our our friend Ben Schwartz did behalf
the voices I love that they got to do
that who this guy one of our friends did
did some of the voice of Ben and Bill
Hader and Bill Hader yeah you know that
by the way that's a that's a sweet gig
oh yeah here's a vocoder and it gotcha
gotcha gotcha that's right burn burn
baby burn burn burn we got you down
thanks so much would you ever do the
soundtrack for a film oh yeah yeah like
seems cool it seems I mean it must be
really really cool oh yeah maybe after
the Arden like cuz yeah Abbi focus I
guess right that's oh my god oh yeah it
feels like that would bring you back to
life I think just hold you just hold the
oh nice yeah there we go
protect yourself protect yourself oh yes
I don't like games that's right exactly
Pernell things are back we got time for
one more game we got seven one more
games you cheat you're a match
absolutely alright or should we try to
chase Rowi what do you think we try to
chase her a ghost I kind of want to hit
up what chase Jade let's choose yeah we
gotta prove ourselves we got a hold on
gotta prove ourselves here it's just
under my ceiling my team it's just under
my skin it's just it's just it's just
gotten to me oh yeah oh yeah all right
row II I'm gonna see where you're at
it's gonna be amazing
yeah I do so you would be through you
would to be to do music for a video game
would be amazing you would look yeah
tracks and video games like Gran Turismo
and stuff like that you know we're not
made right on purpose they took your
they changed your music that was bad I
mean I wasn't really aware of that okay
you weren't aware of it but kind of
before it happened it was no I mean I
was playing actually the Grand Jury so I
was like is it true yeah oh my god the
Silurian came you know down the screen
scrolling oh wait that was yeah you do
that's awesome I know to be part of the
video game would be that's that's an
amazing at you wait did you do the gta4
thing with those back in the day yeah
yeah we have like a little like void
like a couple of voices in Grand Theft
Auto but it wasn't like that no yeah I
mean that's like a whole other whole
other world we just did it cuz like are
haters for the free video okay yeah and
one of our co-worker a girl used to work
here's boyfriend worked at okay Devon
Winterbottom his last name was winter
bata but everybody called summer top
that's a real thing is that weird
I swear to God super weird also Devon
Winterbottom is the perfect name for
like a person out of Lord of the Rings
Harry Potter say you know I said him
super Incredibles words yeah exactly
he's like one of the worst oh it's too
many mushrooms
see you later Nick fandom alright this
is it this is this is it are you ready
are you ready focused let's do it
stretch it out stretch it out dolls
oh man and the voice oh here we go here
we go here we go go left all the way
left okay just jokin we will tell yes a
random Conan and a random person
internet really likes him
we will tell them that all right here we
go this is it man this is it we only got
week all right here we go all right I'm
in red Oh someone's asking for a Yoda
impression row a what do you got
you gotta distract him as much yes you
remember the name looks like yes he's at
5 IG 88 what's the loading capacity of
Boba Fett spaceship they've won slave
why won't damn it I love that this
technique is perfect yeah you know like
they used a synthesizer to do the Alta
g2 stuff what's that synthesized icon
yeah okay it's working perfect it is
working I'm catching up to him wait is
that true but are tdz yeah like I I led
that day they were using this Oberon
synthesizer that was called an Obi one
pass over you ye and then one and then
maybe relates to Dinanath
that's hilarity the name of this guy you
know I was right on top of them oh yeah
a sliding from IC meas in red red bling
right you will know yeah I'm right
behind him I've never won he's going to
the top by the blue sliding on the green
is it - yeah
DeJong Williams wrote all the stuff from
Star Wars yeah like can you remember
that oh man he's in yellow he's running
towards green he's run done he's green
green going yeah I'm going up to the top
going up to the finish and blue blue
he's in blue go up to the top blue go up
to the top yeah I'm here I know he's
going it's a green slide down David I
just had him
feels good guys
no strategy about questioning him was
definitely you know what I'm doing good
I'm so sorry for fighting really I'm
vibing right now well I've got to commit
a murder
um so they'll do it for Monday melee
Fred Falke everybody does he Pete how I
thought now look for that album next
year as well as roie's blood on my hands
yeah some exactly which is gonna be
ridiculous as always for a sketch I room
yes um I thank you guys for joining us
we'll see you guys next Monday
you